on dit que pour exister il faut tuer le
père j'ai pas le sentiment que marine
est tué le père et qu'elle ait voulu le
tuer d'ailleurs c'est ce qui peut-être
ce qui est reproché par un certain
nombre de gens y compris chez elle n'a
pas tué le père il n'a pas pris sa
retraite non plus président d'honneur du
fn jean marie le pen est candidat aux
élections européennes en 2014 il
continue à faire des meetings et à
donner son avis qui diverge parfois de
celui de sa fille comme il nous l'a
expliqué au cours d'un entretien réalisé
à saint cloud dans la propriété
familiale du parc de montretout jean
marie le pen bonjour bonjour on est ici
dans votre bureau à montretout un
l'endroit où vous travaillez je crois
plus que siège du front national
alors dans ce bureau il ya beaucoup de
choses et notamment toute une pile de
livres sur vous que vous avez accumulé
vous archives et tout ce qu'on écrit sur
vous vous savez que lors de tout un
ensemble de livres il a à peu près d'une
centaine qui on est et qu'il soit sur
moi soit maintenant à partir sur mariné
ou même sur marion hannon espèce de
connexion dynastique et alors ça vous
inspire quoi ça vous amuse ou s'est dit
au contraire nous énerve ça vous
embarras donc je constate que beaucoup
des gens qui ont écrit ses livres ne se
sont pas donné la peine de me rencontrer
donc ils se sont bornés à copier sur
leurs prédécesseurs
souvent c'est l'inconvénient c'est la
répétition des erreurs qui ont été
commises préalablement voilà que je ne
dois pas toujours corriger
d'accord mais justement on va revenir
dans l'émission au fil de l'émission sur
différentes choses qui ont été dites sur
vous sur l'image que vous avez pu
renvoyer à différents moments reviendra
sur tout ça mais auparavant donc vous
êtes dans le paysage politique depuis
1956 date où vous êtes élu à l'assemblée
nationale puis dans le paysage sans
interruption depuis les années 80
période où le fn fait ses premiers gros
score alors pendant toutes ces années
votre positionnement votre discours ou
un petit peu évolué vous allez nous
expliquer
mais avant je vous propose d'écouter ce
qu'en dit le politologue pascal
perrineau
ça commence dans les années 80 quand le
fn est clairement une composante de la
droite je vous montre je suis le seul à
la frontière dit libéral et vous êtes
contre le protectionnisme
je suis contre le procès de jean pour la
libre circulation des biens de
consommation des objets absolument
pourquoi est-ce que vous êtes contre la
libre circulation des personnages
le front national n'est pas le front
libéral et parce qu'il considère qu'il y
à un principe supérieur qui est celui de
la nation que je savais bien qu'un parti
libéral sur le plan économique
sans vouloir pour autant que son pays
soit ouvert aux quatre vents et livré à
l'occupation de peuples étrangers
voilà donc on est en 1985 elle a oublié
mais à l'époque jean-marie le pen se
définit comme libéral économiquement et
puis son discours va évoluer
par exemple en 2002 lorsqu'il est
qualifié au second tour vous les mineurs
les métallos les ouvrières jésus ouvrier
de toutes ces industries ruiné par
l'euro mondialisme de maastricht vous
les agriculteurs aux retraites de misère
est acculé à la ruine et à la
disparition
j'appelle les françaises et les français
quelle que soit leur race leur religion
ou leur condition sociale à se rallier à
cette chance historique le redressement
national dans les années 80 la dynamique
du front national se fait avant tout
dans l'espace des droites se sont toutes
une série des lecteurs qui viennent de
la droite classique qui sont exaspérés
par la victoire de la gauche en 80 qui
sont déçus de l'attitude du rpr et de
l'udf qui vont nourrir la dynamique
électorale et le premier programme du
front national est vraiment un programme
au plan économique libéral on est dans
l'ère de la reagan nomix ah oui d'accord
il n'est plus et voilà il est plus
libérale finalement que le rpr et c'est
à partir des années 90 et du début des
années 2000 tout a changé
la crise s'est installée
et la dénonciation de la globalisation
économique de la mondialisation s'est
installée et à ce moment là le discours
est nettement infléchi il faut pas
attendre marine le pen c'est avec jean
marie le pen que ce discours commence
les temps ont changé jean marie le pen
qui est un homme de foi certes mais
aussi un pragmatique s'adapte et il
parle à une nouvelle clientèle
électorale issue massivement des milieux
populaires clientèle électorale pour
laquelle si vous voulez l'auto
libéralisme n'a aucun sens
alors on a beaucoup parlé de l'
influence de marine le pen à elle se
fait sentir particulièrement 2007 ou
celle qui coordonne la campagne de son
père je vous montre un extrait d'un
reportage première nouveauté le logo
reste discret plus qu'une évolution
cette affiche marque une révolution
une jeune femme d'origine étrangère avec
un pire sims eu la lèvre
elle est censée symboliser l'échec de
l'intégration pour ce projet de marine
le pen n'aurait pas plu à tous les
cadres du parti
car lors de chaque présidentielle le fn
en images c'est avant tout le pen avec
auparavant des slogans chocs comme 3
millions de chômeurs c'est 3 millions
d'immigrés de trop depuis quelques
semaines changement de discours hu à
jean marie le pen
je vous invite vous tous qui aimait la
france à vous réunir autour de ma
candidature oui tous et vous aussi
français d'origine étrangère je vous
invite à nous rejoindre
qu'est ce qui se passe dans ces années
2006 2007
le front national est en perte de
vitesse après le choc de 2002 il est en
perte de vitesse pourquoi parce qu'il ya
le phénomène sarkozy et il y a nécessité
pour le président du front national et
ceux qui l'entourent de trouver une
tactique pour récupérer ses électeurs
qui hésite quelque part entre nicolas
sarkozy et jean marie le pen
la stratégie ou la tactique cauchois et
de se draper dans les plis du drapeau
national de jouer sur le thème de la
république
cela annonce quelque part les évolutions
qu'en 2011 2012 marine le pen devenue
présidente du front national est bien
aux évolutions
quel accenture ans ça vous embête tout
ça vous fait plaisir qu'on dit que vous
êtes un bon tacticien que vous avez eu
aussi une stratégie active que monsieur
perrineau fait une erreur qui lie à sa
profession de politologues et il pense
que tout ce que dit un homme politique
il le dit exclusivement en relation avec
la le corps électoral à conquérir mais
on n'a pas forcément un discours qui est
destinée à essayer de l'aider convaincre
ou de les attirer mais on voit bien là
par exemple facilement on voit qu'il ya
eu une évolution qu au début vous êtes
là vous avez un discours économique
libérale et ça évolue alors pourquoi ça
et c'est parce que le monde a changé
donc je défends une politique notamment
de liberté de l'entreprise c'est parce
que de ce que nous vivons dans un monde
socialiste
oui les alliés même et l'europe et le
monde un monde communiste et par
conséquent je prend le contre-pied de
cette pensée dominante en quelque sorte
et puis la situation évolue leur le
communisme va s'effondrer et lassitude
ou alors entrés dans l'union européenne
ce dont on ne parle pas là en
l'occurrence qui va contraindre la
france et lui retirer progressivement
les éléments de sa souveraineté d'accord
donc vous dise effectivement c'est une
évolution qui est liée à l'évolution du
contexte et de la situation et qui a
aimé et qui s'est accompagnée aussi
d'une évolution de votre électorat pour
le coup quand même qu'il va bien sûr
mais c'est évident que l'homme politique
est à l'écouté du peuple français et ils
essayent de déterminer quels sont les
éléments de son avenir
et quels sont les éléments les plus
favorables et bien sûr cette vidéo que
le discours n'est pas le même en
soixante ans de vie publique
encore qu'il ait des constantes oui on
voit aussi les constantes et alors
justement ça pose la question du rôle de
marine le pen on a beaucoup dit en 2007
on a revu les extraits là avec les
affiches avec la jeune femme burrow
gagnon d'hystérie qui vous avez poussé à
lille lyon nice femmes étrangères s'est
pas aller pas d'origine étrangère
elle est française a elle fait peut-être
française oui c'était elle peut être des
dom tom il peut être d'origine
algérienne mais je me signale qu'il ya
eu une algérie française qui avait des
citoyens français en algérie
par conséquent c'est déjà un point de
vue
et de critiquer hostile de souligner
cela comme c'est fait dans comme c'est
fait dans le sujet vous dites d'accord
et cette évolution sur les thèmes les
thèmes de la république valmy et c'est
en fait ce que dit pascal perrineau sais
que c'est vous en fait c'est votre
évolution puisque ça elle poussé par
votre fille
c'est que nous on sait écouter l'homme
politique dans son message tient compte
de la réalité telle qu'elle est
constituée par les faits par les
événements mais aussi par les manoeuvres
de ses concurrents ou de ses adversaires
et dans la mesure où on nous oppose un
front républicain arc républicain je
vais à valmy dire nous aussi nous sommes
républicains
d'accord c'est aussi une manière de
retourner le discours de entre
guillemets l'adversaire d'accord c'est
de la tactique politique ne se fait pas
normal bien sûr et votre fille là dedans
parce qu'on a beaucoup dit c'était elle
en 2007 c'était rare écouté ma fille d
dirige la campagne électorale et pour
tous est grande son influence joue celle
des collaborateurs des gens qui sont
autour de nous nous faisons des dés
comment dirais-je
nous élaborons une une doctrine
collective et dans ce domaine marine le
pen apporte en effet le sa jeunesse sa
censure
la particule à l'époque le
particularisme de sa féminité et c'est
alors il ya quand même la question et
vous l'avez évoqué vous même et que moi
en préparant les missions on a visionné
beaucoup de choses du moc oublie
peut-être pas tout autant que ceux qui
sont dans votre bureau mais enfin il ya
toujours une question qui qui traverse
un petit peu vous concernant c'est jean
marie le pen
est-il stratège ou pas ces déclarations
sont-elles tacticienne ou pas voilà on
vous prête toujours beaucoup d'arrières
pensées
alors oui sauf si oui je vais vous
montrer un extrait vous allez me dire
parce que notamment sur ce qui concerne
à ce que certains appellent vos
provocations d'autres vos dérapages
alors je vous propose de revenir
justement sur un sujet qui date de 2005
commenté toujours par le politologue
pascal perrineau et puis vous réagissez
tout ce matin jean marie le pen est déjà
sur les ondes
le président du front national persiste
et signe il ne change pas une virgule à
ses propos publiés dans l'hebdomadaire
d'extrême droite rivarol
oui en france l'occupation allemande n'a
pas été particulièrement inhumaine même
s'il y eut des bavures au bout de 60 ans
je crois que quand halak quand on la
compare à l'occupation d'un certain
nombre d'autres pays européens
il faut reconnaître que nous avons
toutes choses égales d'ailleurs moins
souffert que d'autres pays comme la
hollande la belgique
rien à ajouter non plus sur le drame
d'oradour sur glane
il y aurait beaucoup à dire at il laissé
entendre dans l'hebdomadaire selon une
thèse révisionniste ce sont des
explosifs dissimulés dans l'église par
les résistants qui aurait fait périr le
10 juin 1944 près de 650 civile et non
l'armée allemande
pour les spécialistes de l'extrême
droite cette nouvelle affaire s'inscrit
dans une véritable stratégie politique
c'est savamment calculé on peut pas
parler d'improvisation pour
une interview qui a été donné comme on
dit la presse écrite donc c'est pas la
télé c'est quand la radio il n'y a pas
de lapsus c'est très contrôlée il a pu
relire et la pub modifie jacomo contre
les chats comme au tout ça vraiment est
complètement maîtrisé et donc ça relève
d'une stratégie indiscutablement et là
ça repose la question qui se pose à
chaque fois que jean marie le pen ne
revenait sur le devant de la scène avec
c'est entre guillemets dérapages c est
ce une stratégie délibérée comme on le
suggère la sur cet extrait ou alors
est-ce vraiment est ce que ça nous
échappe sel naturel qui revient au galop
et qu'il n'arrive pas à se contrôler
j'ai voulu y aller tous les deux qu'ils
s'expriment via la fois la nature
profonde et la culture profonde de jean
marie le pen quand il porte un jugement
qui est un jugement de caractère
révisionnistes sur certains éléments de
l'histoire de la seconde guerre mondiale
c'est le font certainement de sa pensée
qui s'exprime
et puis en même temps que cette nature
profonde s'exprime il y associe
stratégique
on sait très bien dans la vie de tout
parti politique ou de tout leader
politique qu'on traverse de temps en
temps des creux on ne parle plus de vous
les thèmes que vous qui est véhiculé ne
sont plus à l'agenda
et donc il y à la stratégie du scandale
vous revenez dans l'agenda politique
comme on dit vous revenez dans
l'actualité politique en effet par sur
le mode du scandale je suis celui par
lequel le scandale arrive et d'autres
parcours jean marie le pen il faut
savoir que cela correspond à une
stratégie très ancienne parce que en
faisant scandale
il n'apparaît pas comme étant un homme
politique comme un autre
tout de suite forcément comme il fait
scandale on le dénonce
et il peut ensuite retourné cette
dénonciation disant voyez bien comme
vous les petits les sans grade je suis
une victime une victime du système
donc vous dites vraiment ça lui
correspond mais ça correspond aussi à
une vraie stratégie mais pour le coup
pas du tout celle de sa fille elle a
souvent expliqué et alors à l'époque
quelques mois après ce dérapage sur
l'occupation allemande
elle écrit un livre et elle revient sur
ces événements sur le plateau de thierry
ardisson
c'est un trait de caractère qui fait
qu'encore une fois il prend du recul sur
les choses et quand il a dit
l'occupation allemande n'a pas été celle
du maine je pense que il faisait
référence à ce qu'elle a pu être dans
d'autres pays mais c'est vrai que dit
comme ça ça peut ça peut étonner et ça
peut choquer ça peut lui c'est moi je
comprends ça je dis ah mais je suis
absolument persuadé que c'est pas son
but
c'est un enfant de la guerre voilà je
crois que les enfants de la guerre ne
réagisse peut-être pas de la même
manière que nous qui sommes des enfants
de la paix en même temps c'est ce ce
moment là cet épisode là qui va qui va
créer une brouille entre eux oui c'est
peut-être ce moment là qui crée une
brouille entre eux il ya des bruits qui
peuvent être utiles aussi lorsqu'elles
sont présentés gérer sur le terrain
médiatique
parce que pour une jeune femme qui a
vécu dans l'ombre de son père c'est un
moyen d'exister et on sait que marine le
pen dans l'ombre tutélaire envahissante
de son père a besoin d'exister et qu'une
brouille éventuellement passagère ça
vous permet voilà d'exister par vous
même et vous riez qu'est ce qui vous
fait un jury d'avoir ce que monsieur
perrineau est un homme du système et la
différence qui entre tous et gloucester
delà de la deuxième guerre mondiale
c'est qu'ils n'ont pas connue moi j'ai
vécu la guerre je n'ai vécu cruellement
je suis un orphelin de la guerre eux ils
ont lu dès qu'on avait souffert de la
guerre pour les livres voilà risquez
d'élire qui généralement était quand
même plutôt orienté tous de la même
manière plutôt quand même du côté
soviétique ou communistes ou alliés même
que d autres ah ben moi j'ai la mémoire
et se souviennent tout cela et quand je
porte un jugement
même s'il est porté par un journaliste
qui trahit sa profession car il rapporte
des propos qu'il n'était pas dans son
interview
mais qui étaient postérieurs à son
interview il a d'ailleurs été poursuivi
pour cela mais en l'occurrence je ne
renie haut que moi je ne fais pas de
calcul je dis ce que je pense
mam la conception que j'ai de ma vie
politique me permet d'avoir cette
liberté la paix cher parce qu'elle me
vaut beaucoup d'adversité
mais je dis ce que je pense et je le
fais pas de calcul
je ne fais pas de provocation et si
provocation il ya c'est qu'elles sont en
effet provoqué par les gens qui me
posent des questions c'est
là parce que d'accord parce que vous
dites pour faire un don vous dites donc
rivarol vous avez été piégé à l'époque
et vous avez donc attaqué le journal
mais cela dit vous assumez vos propos et
le jour vous les avez toujours assumé et
et vous fait pas de calculs pas de
stratégie ce qu'on vous prête on vous
prête toujours des stratégies et des on
dit que vous êtes un provocateur
oui mais ça ce sont mes adversaires qui
disent la voilà bien sûr et la vérité
souvent provocatrice elle est provocante
en tout cas quand le mensonge règne
on voit aussi qu'il ya des il ya des
moments où vous refusé de revenir sur
certains sujets etc
voilà vous vous dites attendait ne leur
parlerai pas de ça il y aurait beaucoup
à dire notamment sur adour sur glane
mais je n'en parlerai pas c'est parce
que vous avez peur du procès peur de
provoquer peur de nom c'est parce que
j'ai abandonné j'estime que j'en ai
assez dit voilà c'est dans le cloud vous
parlez toujours du vin dans l'interview
qui n'a pas été un interview ce sont des
propos personnels qui sont rapportés par
un journaliste qui trahit sa mission
voilà c'est le journaliste de rivarol
disons le franchement oui c'est vrai
qu'on en a beaucoup parlé mais du coup
avec le recul c'est quelque chose qui
vous a fait beaucoup de tort aux
finalement vous l'assumez comme vous
dites
écoutez ça m'a fait peut-être beaucoup
de torts mme et c'est ce que j'ai dit je
n'ai pensé par conséquent je ne renie
pas ce que j'ai pensé c'est vrai que
c'est su si souvent sur ces sujets là et
sur beaucoup d'autres en désaccord avec
la pensée unique avec la pensée
dominante avec le conformisme politique
de notre temps c'est vrai et vous êtes
aussi du coup et à l'époque et
aujourd'hui on est d'accord avec votre
fille ma fille à ses propres ses propres
idées elle a 40 ans de moins que moi
elle est une jeune femme de son temps
bien sûr elle n'a pas du tout vécu les
mêmes expériences que moi mais
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'elle dit très
intelligemment dans sa dans son
interview
moi je suis d'abord six enfants de la
deuxième guerre mondiale de la guerre
d'indochine de la guerre d'algérie etc
auxquels j'ai participé la sueur après
tout les gens qui ont connu la guerre
n'ont pas forcément la même lecture et
non pas forcément dire bien sûr ils
n'ont pas la même expérience de la vie
c'était mais la même vision ils ont vécu
ça à vif en quelque sorte alors que
encore une fois les autres ne l'ont
vues ou connu qu'à travers des prismes
que j'accuse pour ma part tout vent
d'être partiaux et pascal perrineau dit
aussi bon il parle de cette brouille qui
a eu en 2005 on va passer avec un très
beau et le bon ce sont des choses qui
arrivent on parle peu de pâte très bien
ne pas partager sur le fond ou la forme
d'une expression politique voilà et puis
et puis voilà je pense que marine aurait
beaucoup plus d'indulgence maintenant
qu'elle a l'expérience des
responsabilités à ce moment là être
encore si j'ose dire brut de décoffrage
à vous pensez que c'est ça qui a
expliqué aussi ça ça entre guillemets
car oui il était nouvelle tout de même
dans la dans la proche de ces problèmes
là elle n'avait pas elle même été
attaqué et c'est depuis elle s'est
rattrapée et alors pascal perrineau dit
aussi que cet épisode a permis à votre
fille de s'émanciper finalement que ça
lui a servi et c'est le moment où ça
allait un peu décidé de se lancer dans
le je m'en tire bien jusqu'en avril par
il faut tuer le père alors elle a réussi
à le faire avec une petite brouille sans
tuer le père
donc c'est plutôt sympathique pour moi
ouais ouais mais vous n'en avez vous dit
avec le sourire mais c'est vrai que tuer
le père cc c'est ça ouais on dit ça rien
que pour exister il faut tuer le père
bah j'ai pas de sortie bon que marine
est tué le père et qu'elle ait voulu le
tuer d'ailleurs c'est ce que peut-être
il lui est reproché par un certain
nombre de gens y compris chine d'accord
alors aujourd'hui vous l'avez dit un
vote qui est présidente vous l'avez dit
aussi vous resté très actif
vous avez un vrai rôle dans le parti
vous faites des déplacements vous
intervenez dans les médias et parfois on
s'est rendu compte quand même même si
vous voulez vous loué la sagesse de
l'outil vous n'êtes pas toujours à 100%
d'accord avec elle alors on va revenir
là dessus mais d'abord je vous propose
d'écouter ce qu'en dit le journaliste
christophe forcari qui connaît bien le
front national pourquoi voudriez
aujourd'hui lorsqu'il est de libération
parce que c'était un adversaire
politique
c'est même un militant politique il est
d'ailleurs très sympathiques comme homme
et comme journaliste
il est évidemment quelqu'un d'hostile
alors vous allez pas quelqu'un
d'objectifs si vous voulez marine le pen
a surpris cette semaine en se déclarant
pour la retraite à 60 ans en 2007 quand
vous faisait campagne pour la
présidentielle vous vous étiez pour la
retraite à 65 ans pourquoi ce revirement
je ne sais pas si loin
sa marine le pen oui enfin vous avez
raison de la sortie ça de de la
condition des 40 des 40 annuités pas et
c'est la combinaison des deux chiffres
qu'ils croient peut donner la ligne
politique mais c'est à marine le pen
qu'il faut poser cette question ça veut
dire que vous n'êtes pas convaincus par
cette proposition je ne sais pas je ne
les pas étudié dans son détail mais ce
que je sais c'est que il me semble qu'il
faut tenir compte tout de même de
l'allongement de l'allongement de la vie
donc pour vous 65 ans avec le meilleur
âge les jeux pourront donc là je ne
parle pas assez de peine ce soir de vous
c'est mon point de vue un petit peu ce
produit et situations dans lesquelles ce
ne sera pas tout à fait en accord avec
marine le pen et ces cas là sur la
retraite bien c'est possible oui je ne
sais pas a priori comme ça à première
vue oui puisque moi je proposais 65 ans
et qu'elle propose 60 ans il faudrait
peut-être faire une discussion que j'ai
une discussion avec elle pour savoir
quelle a été la motivation de sa
décision
jean marie le pen est pris en tenaille
par rapport à lui même et papa ça fini
c'est à dire que c'est quelqu'un qui va
camper sur ses positions
puis par ailleurs il a une fille qui est
aussi présidente du front national et il
ne peut pas se permettre
étant donné ce qui devait être donné son
poids de dire tous les shaks matin je
suis content ce que dit ma fille je suis
content ce que dit la présidente du
front national alors là on est quand
même faut dire en pleine campagne
présidentielle de 2012
donc c'est particulièrement
embarrassants qui viennent un peu nuancé
la position de sa fille elle l'a pris
comment elles comment elle a géré ça
très exactement je pense qu'aujourd'hui
elle à elle un rapport assez bizarre
avec son père faut voir que jean marie
le pen n'est pas un président d'honneur
petit et très présent carré chaque matin
il va a parlé à la secrétaire de marine
le pen
donc il sait très bien qu'il un poids
dans le mouvement
alors pendant la campagne ils ont eu
effectivement un problème c'est que
jean marie le pen
dit ce qu'il a à dire quand il veut bien
le dire et ça personne ne peut lui mais
interdire même pas ça finit donc il
fallait éviter pendant toute cette
campagne de 2012 qu'on est allé disons
les choses telles qu'elles sont un petit
dérapage de jean marie le pen qui l'a
aurait ruiné tous les efforts de marine
le pen pour apparaître comme une
candidate entre guillemets normale et il
ya eu effectivement cette interrogation
c'est quelle va être la place de jean
marie le pen difficilement contrôlable
dans l'appareil de campagne de marine le
pen on ne pouvait pas le mettre sur la
touche mais pouvait pas non plus le
mettre trop en avant sur les plateaux de
télé au risque que l'incontrôlable se
produisent et donc ils ont effectivement
essayé de trouver une balance pendant
pendant toute la période de la campagne
présidentielle et l'huile appris comment
il l'a senti ça ou connaissant son
caractère un peu je pense pas qu'il ait
dû apprécié beaucoup depuis quelques
jours sur le pen il possible d'adhérer
directement au rassemblement bleu marine
à une structure parallèle au fn est ce
que c'est le début du de la fin du fn je
ne crois pas mais si c'était un si je
dis franchement que je préfère la
formule du front national qui en 40 ans
a fait la preuve de son courage de sa
pérennité de son dévouement et de
maternité vous quand vous n'allez pas
adhéré vous au rassemblement bleus maria
n'ont sûrement pas je suis président
d'honneur du front national je le reste
pourquoi le rassemblement mozarine ça
vous gêne c'est bon ça fait marrer dit
que c'était une voix est écoutée
cette stratégie ne me dérange pas du
tout c'est une stratégie électorale
voilà je crois qu'il ya en toile de fond
quelque chose qui est dans l'air depuis
pas mal de temps dans l'esprit de marine
le pen et qu'il dérange encore plus
c'est qu'on puisse changer le nom du
front national pour changer la marque
changer l'esprit même de ce qui la fonde
et donc ça il admet absolument pas car
il a peur qu'on dilapide l'héritage là
il a peur il a peur je crois aux mains
d'un dévoiement jusqu'à maintenant
marine le pen a réussi à bien concilier
les deux c'est à dire qu'on reste sur
les fondamentaux du front national comme
la préférence nationale
vraiment les grandes lignes font
les grandes lignes de force de ce parti
et en même temps il sait très bien que l
peut pas conquérir le pouvoir tout seul
donc il lui faut entrer dans des
stratégies d'alliance qui forcément à un
moment ou un autre l'obligeront à
réviser son discours et sa sa marge de
manoeuvre
tant que le gardien du temple jean marie
le pen sera là et forcément et 3g trouve
que christophe se bonifie en
vieillissant c'est dommage qu'ils
partent à la retraite
on commençait à être objectif à mort
vous êtes d'accord avec tout ce qu'il
dit alors dit jeudi qu'il se bonifie
très vite se rapproche de l'objectivité
mais il s'en rapproche juste au moment
où il va partir c'est dommage mais en
tout cas là visiblement il a il parle
encore donc profitons nous aurons il est
toujours actif et alors il dit vous êtes
le gardien du temple alors ça vous dit
c'est vrai oui j'en suis le fondateur et
le gardien est l'animateur et le gardien
rehaussée par le gardien mais enfin oui
ou un peu quand même je président
d'honneur je remplis mon rôle je
j'apporte aux mouvements le poids de mon
expérience de dieu de mon vécu comme on
dit aujourd'hui n'est pas cuit ce trône
en mai alors oui même alors du coup il
ya plusieurs choix parce que dans ce
qu'il dit là il ya un point il évoque
quand même un point qui a pu pousser
l'accès à cette fameuse campagne de 2012
il dit voilà on s'est demandé dans
l'entourage de marine le pen qu'elle est
quelle allait être la place de jean
marie le pen de crainte qu'un petit
dérapage de ce produit ce qui ruinerait
les efforts de sa fille enfin bon il
évoquant même des petites tensions qui
appuya voir où ils me bien sûr mais
c'est la vie c'est comme ça dans tous
les mouvements vivant ne sais c'est le
centième des des oppositions qui existe
à l'ump ou parti socialiste bien sûr
mais après c'est vrai que les de
brouiller les disputes offrons au front
national et on en parle peut par contre
est brouillé les disputes à l'ump et au
ps on en parle beaucoup et on les
connaît donc c'est vrai qu'on aura envie
d'en savoir si on a moins au front
national mais s'il y en a il faudrait
que les médias en fassent part voilà ce
qui fait la skins qui dit dit
effectivement et connaissant jean marie
le pen il a il n'a pas dû apprécier
comme ça qu'on essaye un peu de le
mettre de côté
nous
vis à bon dieu c'est la vie je m'étonne
pas ne me choque pas mais je suis assez
grand pour défendre ma place
probablement et vous les défendez
comment votre place en existant en étant
ce que je suis ce que j'ai toujours été
sans sans forfanterie mais non plus sans
accès d'humilité excessif voilà un parce
qu'on a du mal à imaginer c'est vrai que
bon voilà on est en extérieur on se dit
mais comment on sait comment ça se passe
dans son verdict et à venez assister à
un meeting un de mes réunions j'en fais
une tous les 15 jours ou deux tous les
quinze jours vous vous apercevrez que je
regarde quand même une certaine
popularité dans mouvement ça c'est
effectivement effectivement et donc
c'est comme ça en fait c'est ça c'est
votre popularité dans le mouvement qui
vous permet de contrebalancer même je ne
contrebalance pas je remplis mon office
qui consiste à être ce que je suis et à
dire ce que je pense c'est un des
éléments qui constituent je pense là le
le fond de la réflexion de marine
elle tient compte de ce que je dis mais
aussi de ce que disent les autres et de
ce qu'elle pense elle même c'est elle
qui est la responsable moi je n'ai pas
transmis le flambeau pour essayer de
d'anjou et de papables sous la table non
c'est marine qui est présidente du front
national quand j'ai eu une divergence
avec marine
j'essaye de la convaincre et s'ils
n'arrivent pas à la convaincre
eh bien je me j'obéis à la ligne qu'elle
détermine parce que je suis un bon
militant d'accord si elle vous dit il
faut plus parler de ça on laisse tomber
par exemple sur les retraites vous dites
faudrait qu'on ait une conversation vous
avez la conversation et puis vous
appelez mais elle m'a expliqué très bien
que c'est le terme de 60 ans était un
terme très symbolique très important
mais qu'il fallait penser aux annuités
et que par le jeu des annuités on
rétablissait l'équilibré avec les
générations qui avait
kiki était durable si j'ose dire la
preuve j'en suis un peu la preuve
d'accord donc à ce moment là en face sur
le plateau vous n'êtes pas encore tout à
fait calées avec elle sur ce sujet non
mais on n'a pas être calé rien ne dit
dans le front national que jean marie le
pen doit avoir exactement les mêmes
idées que marine le pen n'a rien
d'accord ok et alors il ya quand même
une question aussi qui est évoqué à la
fin à la c'est la question est la
stratégie qui pourrait consister à
changer le nom du parti
là on a l'impression que vous êtes à
fond contre tout feu tout à fait je ne
m'en suis pas caché
je crois que tu oblet roues ou martini
ou pastis ne change pas de marque change
pas de nom parce que ils sont c'est très
difficile d'implanter un parti politique
et le grand mérite du front national
c'est d'avoir duré pendant 40 ans et
donc il a été connu sous un nom qui a
été celui de ses combats de ces
batailles qui expriment à mon avis
parfaitement où le plus parfaitement
possible quelle est la démarche
politique de notre mouvement voilà je
dois vous trouverez donc parfaitement
stupide d'en changer la dénomination
c'est ridicule mais comme vous dites il
est maintenant à militants comme les
autres et si ça se trouve ce sera la
stratégie qui sera choisi oui je pense
je pense que l'immense majorité des gens
qui constitue le congrès du front
national ne feront pas son de votre avis
front national ils ont adhéré au front
national
ça m'étonnerait qu'ils voudraient
changer de nom d'accord d'accord mais il
y en a qui veulent mais vous pensez
qu'ils sont ultra minoritaires
bien sûr il y en a il y en a qui sont
allergiques à sa façon de choses que je
représente sûrement et votre sens ici ça
fait partie ça fait partie des décors
duval des nuances qui existent à
l'intérieur d'un parti politique même
quand il est très uni d'accord mais
maintenant c'est à votre fille
finalement de gérer tout ça a bien sûr
et elle le président c'est elle qui est
responsable
d'accord on peut bien comprendre vous
vous lui dites ce que vous nous avez dit
là ce serait une très mauvaise idée
elle un jour peut décider de le faire à
elf décidé c'est le congrès qui devrait
décider faut qu'elle soit l'ancien
congrès que je suis vivant et présent
j'aime bien je dirai ce que je pense
d'accord d'accord que je ne crois pas
que la question soit d'actualité
on a évoqué les années 80 vous étiez le
plus proche de la droite et c'est vrai
qu'à l'époque on l'a oublié
une barre et on l'a retrouvé en lisant
la presse il y avait il ya vu quelques
alliances locales et puis il ya eu un
moment des tentations d'alliance entre
le front national et le rpr de l'époque
alors on a retrouvé des archives on va
écouter aussi la suite de l'analyse de
christophe forcari qui donc revient sur
cette idée un moment qui avait germé
d'alliance et puis qui explique qu'il ya
un événement qui a tout fait basculer un
événement en 1987 je vous montre vous
l'écoutez et vous réagissez
je suis un passionné aussi par
l'histoire de la deuxième guerre
mondiale je me pose un certain nombre de
questions et je ne dis pas que les
chambres à gaz n'ont pas existé je n'ai
pas pu moi même en voir je n'ai pas
étudié spécialement la question mais je
crois que c'est un point de détail de
l'histoire de la deuxième guerre
mondiale
voulez-vous me dire que c'est une vérité
révélée à laquelle tout le monde doit
croire c'est une obligation morale jeudi
qu' il y à il y à des historiens qui
débattent de ces questions il a
l'immense jeudi quand les historiens ont
dit éprouver exclu que d'autres noms
mais vous même sur le pénal ce que vous
considérez qu'il y a eu un génocide juif
je reviens de loin il ya eu beaucoup de
morts beaucoup de centaines de milliers
peut-être des millions de morts juifs et
aussi de gens qui n'étaient pas juifs
n'est ce pas où on a beaucoup
beaucoup glosé sur sur le dérapage de
jean marie le pen qui est absolument
ignobles est-ce que effectivement c'est
du dérapage de la sortie de route à
contrôler ou est-ce qu'au contraire
c'est sciemment calculer mais dans ce
cas là dans quel but on le voit pas si
ç'avait été calculée par dont le calcul
aurait été très mauvais revenons un peu
en arrière aux municipales de 1983 il ya
une alliance entre le rpr de l'époque et
le fn pour conquérir la mairie de dreux
il ya une attitude de la droite
républicaine à l'époque de 83 à peu près
à 86 qui est très conciliante vis-à-vis
du fn
chirac dire à un moment je cite de
mémoire il est pas pire de s'allier avec
les communistes qui ont du sang sur les
mains que de salies avec avec les avec
le front national
donc la droite n'exclut rien en 86 quand
le fn arrive à l'assemblée nationale
avec un groupe la droite nuit lui
réserve plutôt un bon accueil et à
l'époque jean-marie le pen est plutôt en
train de se dire que effectivement il
peut être dans une stratégie d'alliance
avec la droite qu'il ne l'exclus pas non
plus en voulant être un partenaire à
part entière car nous avons des
positions sur l'ensemble des problèmes
qui sont assez sensiblement différentes
de celles de l'opposition libérale
qu'elle soit udf ou rpr mais néanmoins
et compte tenu des du cadre
institutionnel où je dirais électorale
eh bien nous sommes prêts à des
alliances dans le cadre d'un choix de
société qui est évidemment le même que
celui de l'opposition libérale
même si nous avons des positions assez
différente sur un certain nombre de
problèmes à cette époque carré serait
même le rêve dit on raconte on d'être de
devenir ministre ministre de la défense
par exemple le résultat de ce but de
cette phrase du détail de 1987 va
totalement bouleverser la stratégie du
fn mais surtout totalement modifié
l'attitude de la droite c'est à dire que
à partir de ce moment là le pen
redevient la fréquentable le voyou donc
ils se retrouvent totalement mis au ban
de
de la vie publique ce qui va l'amener
après une fois que ça s'est commis il a
plus d'autre choix que de continuer dans
l' isolement c'est-à-dire non splendide
isolement on le fait comme idole va
devenir ma force
plus on veut pas que je parle ça veut
dire que je suis en train de vous dire
la vérité à vous français alors vous
avez dit mais non pour les alliances
mais là on voit en 83 quand même vous
les évoquer alors est-ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer parce que c'est vrai que
c'est surprenant de voir entendre parler
d'alliance alors christian 83 le rpr
tout à fait prêts à des alliances avec
le front national qui fait 10 % dans les
sondages ou dans les élections d'accord
vous êtes en train de s'écrire mais
comme nous allons commencer à grandir et
devenir des rivaux et bien le rpr va
essayer de nous et tout frais et nous
forcari se trompe tout à fait quand il
dit que 86 je suis prêt à une
négociation quelconque puisque je
l'appelle le premier geste que nous
faisons en arrivant au palais ces deux
refusés justement notre confiance à
jacques chirac aux séquelles c'est clair
et que lui établi un nouveau système
électoral qui est d'apprendre qu'il
supprime la proportionnelle qui les a
justement permis d'arriver ou pas au
palais bourbon
mais oui effectivement compassionnel qui
avait été là pour les élections de 86
alors il ya toujours eu cette rivalité
c'est vrai qu'en relisant les articles
de presse de l'époque c'est vrai qu'en
même temps vous êtes très critique
vis-à-vis de jacques chirac dans les
articles et en même temps vous demandez
j'ai retrouvé un article vous demander
cinq postes de ministres
vous réclamez un moment j'ai retrouvé un
article des années 80 où il réclamait à
la droite cinq postes de ministres un
long mais non vous l'avez jamais fait
vous avez jamais réclamé l'argent c'est
peut-être qu il faut le mettre dans son
contexte je sais pas vous mais city ça
comme ça une phrase comme ça me paraît
moins mirobolants que jamais prononcé
cette phrase ou alors elle est prononcée
de façon ironique ou dans le canada dans
un contexte qui est différent d'accord
mais vous sérieusement du coup parce
qu'il dit effectivement que vous avez un
moment envisagé d'être ministre à janine
homps j'étais écoutez j'ai été
rapporteur du budget de la guerre en
après 58
n'est ce pas de la guerre d'algérie
j'étais rapporteur du plus gros budget
la scion quitté le budget de la guerre
et mais je n'ai pas du tout pensé à
pouvoir être ni souhaité être ministre
dans les gouvernements de la décadence
d'accord et donc son analyse tout à
l'heure vous si vous étiez d'accord avec
toi là vous êtes pas
tous d'accord sur l'analyse sur cette
phrase sur le point de détail qui aurait
établi un cordon sanitaire autour de
vous et qui vous aurait poussé en jeu
comment dirais-je la constatation qu'il
fait que cette phrase a déclenché une
hostilité générale et pour ma part
encore aujourd'hui incompréhensible mais
il doit y avoir des raisons secrètes
probablement qui le justifie moi je ne
les comprends pas et d'ailleurs depuis
jeu comme c'est un sujet dont il est
interdit de parler sous peine de
condamnation en correctionnelle
eh bien je trouve je dis moi quand on me
pose la question
l'ailier côté je crois en effet je me
suis trompé c'est c'est c'est la
deuxième guerre mondiale qu'ils étaient
un détail de l'histoire des chambres à
gaz
donc il a il a raison sur le cordon
sanitaire rudiments mais pas sur le fait
que ça à modifier votre stratégie nous à
navarra je continue mon combat dans dans
la droiture dans le courage de la vérité
voilà c'est chez ce n'est pas la même
que celle de monsieur chirac c'est sûr
pour terminer les missions voilà vous
disiez à je suis moi droit je suis en
europe et m'a justement on pas dit le
feu zarrouk on vous l'avait pas dit
malheur c'est parce que la l'intervenant
le dit alors que vous aviez je suis
droit je suis tu je suis marron toi là
je suis ma route sans dévier vous avez
dit ça c'est ça c'est ce que vous
vouliez dire justement c'est parce qu'il
en est question dans le magnéto suivant
je vais vous montrer quelques images des
images de prise sur le vif des images
avec votre fille des images où vous
parler d'elles elles sont commentés par
le philosophe et psychanalyste
jean-pierre winter on commence par
quelques images
jean pierre winter
hu a suivi de près je suis venu
aujourd'hui puisqu'il ya je n'ai pas pu
et comme demain et pas la ville
encourage repart avec l'oscar à musique
voilà donc là pour le coup ce faire à
leur tour
d'après vous qu'est ce qu'elle a dit
vous votre fille casque la boue pardon
elle sera aussi bonne que vous comme ça
je sais rien c'est l'avenir qui le dira
j'espère qu'il sera meilleur parce
qu'elle a quand même déjà
moi j'ai fait le bulldozer a fait tracer
la route dans la jungle
maintenant elle peut aller plus loin
sans doute je le souhaite en tous les
cas hier un challenge entre
résultat oui j'allais défi challenge en
français c'est comme les j'ai remarqué
que les speakers de la piste de la radio
10 vancouver vancouver c'est vancouver
c'est pendant le gala il faut dire rangs
du corps
qu' il dise qu'il affirme qu'il souhaite
qu'elle aille plus loin que lui
on peut penser que c'est vrai et comme
beaucoup de pères avec leurs enfants
c'est souvent le souhait qui est qui est
exprimée ça ne dit rien de l'ambivalence
qu'on peut avoir
l'égard de ses enfants quand on est
comme ça
une fille qui va prendre votre
succession dans l'entreprise tout le
monde sait les conflits intrafamiliaux
dont il n'a effectivement pas à nous
faire part dans une émission de
télévision et sur son attitude à elle
parce qu'on la sent souvent un petit peu
c'est pas les relations quoi on la sent
essayant de faire bonne figure
du coup elle sourit de toutes ses dents
mais d'une manière qui paraît vraiment
forcer à elle vous dit elle a l'air un
peu mal à l'aise pas lui en tout cas lui
les îles et il a toujours eu cette force
de conviction de sentiment d'être dans
comme ils disent dans la droiture d'être
dans le vrai dans la vérité qui fait que
c'est une espèce de menhirs sait il
aimerait il aimera l'image je suis sûr
et rien ne peut rien ne peut altérer la
position qui est la sienne et on ne l'a
jamais entendue malgré les témoignages
malgré les procès on l'a jamais entendu
revenir sur sur quelque chose qui leur
ai dit et qui aurait fait du tort
après tout ça peut arriver à n'importe
qui de dire voilà je me suis laissé
entraîner où je n'étais pas suffisamment
informé où je n'avais pas conscience de
la douleur des gens à qui je m'adressais
et donc je le regrette et j'espère que
que comme le pardonnera n'ont jamais
s'est jamais arrivé voilà alors il ya
deux choses à reprendre parle du début
vous avez ri quand il a dit oui quand
vous fairy parfois elle a l'air un peu
mal à l'aise
ça vous fait pourquoi vous avez ri parce
que vous pensez aussi se met dans la
peau des gens il croit que ça et c'est
souvent les psychologues pensa les
psychiatres et psychanalystes
on n'est pas forcé de les croire
d'accord non mais c'est vrai aussi
femmes on est tous un pour les femmes on
est tous si notre père on a vu une
martine aubry d'ailleurs une femme
politique aussi qu'il n'est pas
forcément qu'il est souvent mal à l'aise
quand elle quand elle était filmé avec
j'ai pas trouvé du tout que les images
montraient que voilà vous qui la
connaissent que marine de quelqu'un
d'assez expansif assez extraordinaire
qu'elle porte
l'accord donc elle n'est pas donc vous
dites finalement elle est parfaitement
naturel elle n'est pas dans cette
relation qui peut être compliqué dès
fois perf' ya pas non non c'est sûr elle
vous n'y a pas de malaise n'y a pas de
très bien et alors sur les regrets aussi
parce qu'il dit ah vous avez dit cahuzac
un pendant qu'il parlait il dit tout
être humain peut exprimer des regrets en
disant j'ai mal compris je me suis c'est
très à la mode la mode américaine cetc
clinton avouant qu'il avait chuté dans
son bureau sa petite secrétaire et
caetera et après il bat sa coulpe à
redon je ne suis pas mon genre voilà
wave ou non jamais non ce que je demande
pardon cadieux doivent pas pardon aux
hommes mais comme cette histoire de
regrets parce qu'on peut dire alors
effectivement je vais au fil des
interviews vous êtes aujourd'hui moi je
regrette pas j'ai jamais exprimé de
regret etc
mais après vous allez dire c'est votre
affaire et ça nous regarde pas forcément
même temps peut dire chaque personne
peut se dire à moi je me suis fais dans
mon for intérieur dans votre film petto
d'accord à ce que sur ces sujets là pour
vous on peut se le dire dans son for
intérieur sans le sucre public bien sûr
absolument le la confession publique
c'est un acte politique que coke ont
fait ou qu'on ne fait pas naître
ça n'a rien à voir avec la la conviction
que l'on a de son erreur éventuelle etc
mais c'est différent donc vous vous le
faites vous pouvez être amené à le faire
mais vous le gardez pour vous c'est ça
éventuellement et vente éventuellement
d'accord éventuellement est donc si
éventuellement vous étiez amené à avoir
des regrets sur quelque chose et qu'on
vous pose la question sur ce sujet là
vous rangez qu'angers
et du tort à quelqu'un je n'hésite pas à
lui en demander pardon si j'ai fait si
j'ai commis une erreur ou une faute à
son égard une injustice ça ne me gêne
pas de cette individuelle mais sur le
plan politique jusqu'à présent je ne me
suis pas trouvé dans cette situation là
même même en votre for intérieur
will power de manoeuvre bon prêter le
flanc à un adversaire
ça n'est pas s'être trompé oui mais s'il
faut en passer par là pour que c'est pas
à moi à gagner des élections etc
non mais écoutez il ya des choses que je
ne ferais pas même pour gagner des
élections vient jamais bon ou pour que
votre fils et gagne 1 c'est elle qui est
maîtresse de son jeu oui mais ce que si
vous deviez faire quelque chose pour que
votre fille puisse gagner une élection
vous feriez demander pardon de certaines
choses pour que votre fille non je ne
sens pas de ne voudrais pas payer de ce
prix là il ya d'autres certainement
d'autres manière plus noble plus loyal
de le faire d'accord très bien en tout
cas merci beaucoup de nous avoir accordé
cet entretien
merci donc on fait si aussi de m'avoir
invité c'est d'autant plus remarquable
que c'est rare